so if you aren't already aware apple
just came out and announced
three brand new products all running
apple silicon
but what does that mean for us
architects around the world in 2020
well today we're going to find out
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
today we're looking at the three brand
new products from apple
the macbook air the macbook pro and the
macbook mini
we're going to be looking at the apple
silicon architecture what this
m1 chip is and what it truly means for
us architects out there in 2020.
simply put the m1 chip is a combination
of multiple parts
previously used and combined through the
intel chip system
to make the computer powerful and run
now the m1 chip
combines some of the most powerful and
most important elements
in your computer today the m1 chip
combines
your cpu your gpu your graphics card
your data and power management and also
your security
it does a whole bunch of other features
as well but this is the primary elements
that truly contribute to how we operate
our systems from a day-to-day basis
some simple facts and figures for you
2.8 times
faster cpu five times faster gpu
and 5.9 times faster rendering
all of those sound fantastic if you're
comparing it
to your old device so if you're running
a macbook
pro right now you're gonna get two times
faster
cpu performance as an archicad user
myself personally speaking
i know that this will genuinely result
in a much better performance
when operating the system archicad runs
on predominantly
cpu requirements it only boots up the
graphics card
when you enter the 3d engine or when you
go into something
like twin motion and doing some
visualization i was in a meeting a
couple weeks ago discussing apple
silicon with the graphisoft team
and they personally said to me that they
have known about apple silicon for a
very long time now
and they are already ahead of the game
making sure that graphisoft is
compatible
once it launches which is now if you
just think about archicad and how
archicad started back in the day
it was originally approached by steve
jobs personally
to bring archicad to the apple software
so graphisoft and apple have a very
close
relationship and that will truly show as
we move forward
and graphisoft becomes even more
powerful and even more stable on
the new m1 chip breaking down the three
individual products
and potentially which one might be the
best for you as an architect in 2020
if you were to go out and purchase any
one of these
well it is a very tough decision to
break down
the cons first of all the macbook air
has
no fans and that is not a play on words
it is
actually genuinely a product without
any fans cooling the device
i know personally every time i run
archicad and then boot up photoshop
and open up i don't know twin motion and
then some illustrator and maybe some
chrome
all of a sudden my computer makes a hell
of a lot of noise
my computer behind me which is a custom
built rendering machine
still gets very loud and has to cool all
the time
so personally speaking i don't think the
macbook air
will be able to handle the power
requirements
of an architectural system and an
architectural software package
for the simple fact it won't be able to
cool it in time it'll get extremely hot
and potentially extremely dangerous now
i know the m1 chip is meant to be better
at performance
and thermal efficiency as well as power
management
however i genuinely don't see the
macbook air as a competitor
in the world of architecture in 2020.
stepping up to the macbook pro it does
have some fans
it has some mechanical cooling inside
which means it will be able to pump out
that hot air when it needs to
and also potentially remain very quiet
they are saying it is dead silent
nothing like the previous macbooks
which were annoyingly loud when you
needed to do anything
so this is potentially a truly useful
competitor
now when i say truly useful you have to
take this with a grain of salt
because what i mean is the simple fact
that any laptop you purchase
and if you haven't seen my top 20
laptops for 2020 for architects
i'll link it down below if you want to
take a look
is every laptop isn't going to be your
main daily driver
you really should be looking for a
product like a desktop or an imac
that you can sit at and run 24 7 because
you genuinely need
those high performance cores running all
the time
and not being split 50 50 between high
performance and
high efficiency cores like the m1 chip
is right now
so even though the macbook pro is
powerful enough to run
archicad and in my personal opinion more
than likely powerful enough
to run most projects in archicad to a
medium density scale
maybe five six units at a time
it probably shouldn't be your daily
driver it will however be a genuinely
good device
if you're out on the road going on a
holiday going on a plane trip somewhere
or just a simple work trip
if this is your device that you need to
carry along with you to quickly do some
work
it will be phenomenal however keep in
mind if you are an archicad
usbc dongles are extremely rare and
extremely limited
so you're going to have to go to the
cloud-based software k
options and last but not least the
macbook mini
now this is actually a fan favorite for
me it is a really nice device in a very
small compact package
however it hasn't been upgraded in a
very very long time
so even though it boasts some incredible
figures like 15 times
faster than the previous version of the
mac mini
it hasn't been updated whilst the
macbook pro and the macbook air
have been updated multiple multiple
times
so the macbook mini yes it is
significantly faster than the previous
generation
but it is still a very small compact
package
again i think it is on the same plane as
the macbook pro so if you're looking for
an alternative device
just to quickly run through some
drawings look at some information maybe
make some small changes
phenomenal device if you're looking for
a daily driver
i wouldn't recommend it in a nutshell
the m1 chip is an
extremely powerful and phenomenal step
forward
in innovation and architecture to have
all of your main components combined
into one
talking together as one brings us a step
closer to that
artificial intelligence that everybody's
worried about or dreaming about
if you're using archicad at the same
time it is a hundred percent
cpu based 90 of time unless you're in
the 3d window
so you're definitely going to see some
improved performance improved power
and a very visible noticeable change
from your previous computer
to your brand new m1 chip anyway that's
all for me today guys thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed the
video
if you did make sure you smash that like
button down below to help this video
with the youtube algorithm
and if you want to see more of these
videos smash that subscribe button
leave a comment down below if you want
to see something specific
and as always i will see you next monday